-Yeah!
-Hey!
-Look at you, bud.
Thank you so much
for being here, man.
I love your quarantine hair.
-Thanks.
It's getting long.
-Is this the longest
you've ever had it?
-This is, by far,
the longest I've ever had it.
I was in ponytail --
I'm in ponytail territory.
Not to trigger people
about the ponytail.
It's gonna hang down
for now, but...
-[ Laughs ]
Where are you right now?
-I'm at my girlfriend's house
in Miami,
and that's her dog barking,
if you hear.
He's a Pomeranian.
This is home.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Have you been quarantining
with Camila's family?
-Camila.
Yeah, I have been.
And, you know, it's funny.
At first, when I got here,
it was, like, the beginning
of the album process,
and I was, like,
in a full panic state.
I was like, "There's no way
I'm going to make music.
This is gonna be impossible."
-Yep.
-But, like, a week goes by,
and you start cooking eggs
in the morning,
and you start doing laundry
and taking dogs for a walk,
and you have a coffee mug
that you've used the same one
every day,
and it just becomes,
like, really nice.
-Yeah.
-Becomes nice.
-I mean, I guess you've been --
-Which sounds so normal
for everyone else,
but it's very abnormal for me.
-Well, you've been working
since you were 15
or something like that?
-I was 15,
and I basically have been living
in a hotel room since I was 15.
So, it's been nice, man.
It's been really nice.
-I want to talk about
the new album, "Wonder."
I love the cover, by the way.
-Thanks.
-It comes out December 4th,
but the single is out now,
and you're performing it
later tonight.
How did you come up
with the cover?
-I mean, you know,
I was in Miami.
That's where I am
a lot of time now.
So, I was in Miami,
and we were out on the water,
and I just got the final mix
of the song back,
so I was playing it
on the boat that I was on.
And all my --
Not all my friends.
Like, three and four
of my friends
and Camila were on the boat.
And the song was playing,
and we --
It's just, like,
the skies opened up,
and it started pouring down.
-Yeah.
-This is, like,
my biggest fear is deep water.
So, we all jumped off the boat
in the middle of ocean.
Probably was near land,
but I'm just gonna say it was
in the middle of the ocean.
But in the middle of the ocean,
and it was pouring rain,
and I looked around, and that
was kind of the essence.
So, you could say that
that was either done
in the middle of the ocean,
or in a parking lot in L.A.
It's up to you
how you want to decide
what that photo actually is.
-I just know that feeling,
and I just think it's so cool.
It's, like,
so kind of free, almost.
That's what it feels like.
-Totally.
And, you know, I mean,
I feel like this time around,
you know, I think
especially with the quarantine,
I had a real moment
to find some stillness
and just be quiet with myself,
and also find some confidence
with my work that I was doing,
you know?
There was a real place
inside of me that was scared
of saying something wrong
or doing something wrong,
or, like,
saying the wrong thing.
And I think that,
after kind of chilling out
and reflecting a bit, I found
this place where I realized,
like, when we're talking about
matters of the heart,
you don't have to be an expert.
And the whole album
became about this freedom,
this, like, thing of, like,
not being afraid
of talking about things that you
morally know are right or wrong.
And it allowed me
to just open up.
And that's what
the whole video looks like.
That's what
the artwork looks like.
the music sounds like.
It's just --
It's internal freedom.
-I want to talk about the music,
'cause I think --
There's horns, there's
different sounds in here.
I'm like, "Oh, I want to know
who inspired that."
Like, "What was that?
What was that one?"
-I came back off tour,
and my sister, who is 17 now,
who's really cool, and she's,
like, way cooler than me now.
I mean, there's like -- for some
reason, when girls become 17,
they're like aesthetically --
they know how to do everything,
and they're just
the coolest person in the world.
So, I was like,
"What are you listening to?"
And she played me Frankie Valli,
"Can't Take My Eyes Off of You."
-Really?
-Yeah, totally.
And it just kind of set me off.
And the whole album
was, like, brass, '60s drums.
I got super into The Beach Boys.
And my parents didn't listen to
a lot of The Beatles growing up,
so I started discovering
The Beatles really
for the first time,
and it was pretty magical.
So, that's kind of sonically
where it all came from.
-Is it intimidating when --
You're working on this album.
Camila's there.
-Mm-hmm.
-Do you go, like --
Is it embarrassing,
or do you go like,
"All right, here's this song.
I think it's a good song."
Or is it like,
"Can you help me on this?"
Or what is it like?
-I mean, you have --
You have, like, I think --
I think you have two choices.
You can either, like,
hide everything from her
and just, like,
wait till the end type thing,
and you can decide, or, like,
what I did was, like,
from the very beginning,
I told her my thesis statement
of what I wanted
the album to be.
And it was the best thing I did,
because there's always a point
halfway through a project
where you're like,
"This is garbage.
This is the worst thing
I've ever done.
Everything is not --
It doesn't sound good.
I don't know what I'm doing."
And that's when you need
that support to be like, "No.
Stick with the idea,
because the idea is beautiful,
and it's gonna turn out."
And I probably would've been
discouraged enough to, like,
move into
a different world, sonically,
if I didn't have her kind of
backing me the whole time.
So, I'm thankful for that.
-Yeah, I think she knows
what she's doing, too.
-She knows what she's doing.